ces images ont été filmées hier soir par
un témoin rue des valendons à dijon un
homme vient d'être abattu par arme à feu
alors qu'il se trouvait dans sa voiture
une citroën c3 immatriculée en côte d'or
il est environ 18 heures dépassant donne
l'alerté après avoir entendu plusieurs
coups de feu
on était là donc un attendu le coup de
feu trois fois papin 3 fera donc seul
apparemment elle sait pas sortir
regardez ce qui se fera soit oui j'ai vu
une personne n'était à langer tous y
avait la police chez lui et sami aussi
les pompiers à côté j'ai raconté une
voisine elle m'a dit il y avait un tir
c'est quelqu'un qui était dans une
voiture a tiré sur la personne du coup
ça m'a fait un peu voir dans le deuxième
j'ai rien entendu j'étais chez moi avec
les enfants la victime est un jeune
homme de 30 ans originaire de dijon
il n'a pas survécu à ses blessures et
est décédé dans la soirée pendant
plusieurs heures des patrouilles ont
sillonné le secteur à la recherche d'un
10 seule certitude le procureur de la
république de dijon affirme que la piste
terroriste est totalement exclue selon
les dernières informations le tireur
était accompagné d'une autre personne
mais pour l'instant nous ne connaissons
pas leur identité ni le mobile du crime
l' enquête est en cours elle a été
confiée à la section criminelle de la
police judiciaire de dijon